you can think that way right but yeah
don't be posting it because you're not
only posting it for dagestan people to
see anymore it's for the whole entire
world
I see so now you're they're gonna lose a
bunch of fans and all type of [ __ ] but
yeah I saw the shadows fighters just
problematically or not just fighters I
think a lot of entertainers me including
we forget that the world there's a
public platform now right with Twitter
and social media so I don't really think
about that too much and I realized that
should too specifically with the whole
Deonte of all the thing in the the radio
raheem [ __ ] to this day you know we was
doing that [ __ ]
what was the backstory on that again so
so this is what I thought when I first
saw it right and a lot of people
disagree with me on this and I was I was
like I gave radio raheem a benefit
because I've been on the interviewee
side right yeah and so a lot of the
times what happens with these
interviewers they want you to sound good
they're not there to trash you right
yeah and I'd even know about radio
raheem previous relationship with
Deontay Wilder what was that they've
talked before they've had conversations
they were friends so what these
interviewers will do if they don't prep
you they'll lob you an easy question so
you could thoroughly explain your stuff
right now better and have a good exactly
so somebody says to me about the whole
crazy rich Asians and things right so
they come up to me and they go turning
like a red carpet interview and they go
hey soso is crazy rich Asians very
important for Asian people of media
would I come out and be like what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] do you mean like have
you known that there aren't Asian faces
in the media are you in a [ __ ] hole
what if I said that two of them
conversely right cuz when I heard that
question I was like oh radio Raheem is
lobbing him a question but he took that
as like oh why are you acting like new
[ __ ] Uncle Tom like you don't know
what I'm like what is it what did he ask
he basically asked him about I can't
remember exactly
yeah it's about black culture and kind
of like what what do you what he what
he's trying to stand for in terms of
what black people are going through
today and he's like what you what are
you not black like yeah black man asking
me this [ __ ] yeah you know [ __ ] like
that there's like you're one to write or
some shades I yeah that's you too when
he what he was saying is it's like it
like what Radio Raheem was like dawg we
know each other I know you know I know
this yeah so why the [ __ ] would you come
at me like this like I'm asking what he
was saying too is that this is an
international platform yeah you're also
going get somebody from the UK American
black history
pertains to American people so not he
goes what you don't you'll have the
internet Google that [ __ ] Doug do you
know [ __ ] about Europe Deonte I know you
know anything about Europe if I asked
him on the spot
do you know [ __ ] about Europe do you
know the [ __ ] that black people go
through in Europe you probably don't
know and so because it's an
international platform he's get lobbing
him a question to be like yo and he
botched it and he watched it and then he
made [ __ ] radio Raheem look like an
Uncle Tom which him as an interview he
was like yo I'm lobbying you a good
question so you could look good yeah so
why did you four homies and we're
friends so what the [ __ ] but they
squashed it after wouldnt any started
using that for like merchant [ __ ]
exactly which kind of video is so scary
though it was frightening i think i
remember the video like kind of zooming
in on that he was shocked he's like yo
man like I'm trying to help you out and
also too because there was a narrative
of about um Tyson Fury he's also a gypsy
right yes what he calls himself the
gypsy king I'm not sure if that's a
derogatory term or not I think it is but
I don't really know still lives in a
caravan bro yes he's Caravan yeah he is
a gypsy King and so you know gypsy
people are also people who are looked
down upon so he has his like people
struggle versus the black American
struggle so he was trying to create the
narrative of that versus him saying oh I
don't know what black people go through
in the site bro clearly as a black male
he understands he knows what this is so
he's like oh you're trying to get like a
sensationalized piece right now so like
no you dumbass like what I'm trying to
do is lob you a question as your friend
so you could explain yourself because
your angle right now is that you are
speaking for the people case in point
after he got [ __ ] up in that Tyson
Fury fight he's over here in his room
with the [ __ ] hoodie on or some [ __ ]
don't like my peoples yeah have you seen
yeah I saw let me look that [ __ ] up dude
that's that was enough talking about the
interview sort of something like that
did you guys see the whole thing with
Tony Ferguson like there was kind of a
little story about it about how the
press conference yeah so some press
conference was great well yeah so if you
guys haven't watched the the interaction
between khabib in hubby Habib and and
Tony Ferguson that press conference
I've maybe watch it like two or three
times what's the guy like straight sup
alright so give him yeah seems like you
know Macy like you overcame mental
health apparently that name he's a fight
or two but he also works at he's
ex-military guy too
yeah so he's worked with a lot of like
PTSD and worked through a lot of like
depression things like that so he was
really excited to - so he brings it up
he's like you know you're you're here
you're gonna fight this champion just
really brave yeah bring it's really
break the overcame mental you know
that's a lie and his response to us [ __ ]
you
he was [ __ ] wise yeah and he's like
oh I'm not trying to be he's like [ __ ]
your advice he's next question I'm not
trying to give you advice I'm trying to
give you props but okay yeah it's like
yeah hello dude that I was hearing
seeing people talk about that and that
was like that was the worst response I
should have been like open about it and
be like this is what I did to get here
loud because people are probably
watching Phil in the same way we I also
watched an interview after that press
conference I interviewed 20 Ferguson and
I thought who was I think it was like
Brett Okimoto or something like that and
he starts bringing up like you know he
was talking about who's your team and
xxi mention his wife yeah and then he
was like oh yeah like you and your wife
have gone through and he was like
careful yeah careful careful and I was
like dude but like Tony Ferguson is a
wild man bro I
well Tony Ferguson lives in his own
world so when he responds like that I'm
like that's about Tony Ferguson yeah
yeah it seems alright but have you seen
there's like all these compilations on
YouTube it's called like two or three
minutes of Tony Ferguson trying to
injure himself yeah all these training
oh he does weird [ __ ] but he's also like
it's it's obviously from a coach's
perspective you're like hey don't do any
of that but it's also amazing how good
he is it's also he's also on like a 13
fight win streak bro this month he was
on a hoverboard log pressing like clean
log press SS
lana beach and then back flipping off of
like a BOSU ball I would go train with
him and do this [ __ ] really well you
wouldn't last that no none of us would
last a day cuz we'd all bust our asses
I'd last to
right here dude he's like really sad let
you know that sounds like the behave
like our song is first of all let's
pause this real quick what where did the
Black Panther [ __ ] Wakanda access not
gonna make it was I I am here yo yo ki
yo keen is here you know I don't know
what I'm going to do later but I got hit
in the face real hard hold on Deonte
relax we're safe first of all by the way
I actually love Deontay Wilder because
you got that heater in his hand here but
I thought you took the loss really
poorly we'll talk about the suit after
but we gonna get back on you almost
punches as hard as me okay